-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We're -- Hope you are all
doing well.
I think that came off right.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
New York Mayor Bill de Blasi
announced yesterday
that the city
will hold a parade in July
to honor the coronavirus
pandemic frontline workers
Dude, have you learned nothing
New Yorkers hate parades.
That's like saying you're goin
to honor them
with a trip to Fenway
and some deep dish pizza.
[ Laughter ]
[ New York accent ]
Why the [bleep]
is Fifth Avenue closed?!
[ Laughter ]
First responders,
alright, alright.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Mayor de Blasi
announced yesterday
that the city will hold a parade
to honor the frontline workers
of the coronavirus pandemi
and added it will be
"a parade you'll remember
for the rest of your life.
In other words,
the exact opposite
of the St. Patrick's Day parade.
"How did I even get home
from Midtown?"
[ Laughter ]
Mayor de Blasio also
announced yesterday
that residents who receive
a coronavirus vaccination
at a city-run site
will have the chance to wi
a staycation at a local hotel.
It's a chance for New Yorker
to stay somewhere
even smaller
than their apartment.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
held a dinner
at her residence tonight
for a bipartisan group
of female senators,
but, first, she had a messag
for Arizona Senator
Kyrsten Sinema.
-Do not come.
[ Laughter ]
Do not come.
-That's right,
Kamala Harris held a dinne
at her residence tonight
for a bipartisan group
of female senators
and Susan Collins
is still deciding
between the chicken or the fish.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, I don't know.
Maybe I'll do the chicken.
Or I'll do the fish.
Who knows?
Who knows, with me?"
After visiting the Holocaust
Memorial Museum yesterday,
Republican Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene
apologized for comparing
the coronavirus vaccine mandates
to the Holocaust.
It's like when these folks
learned about democracy
on their field trip
to the Capitol.
[ Laughter ]
According to Politico,
major public housing house
are hesitant to publish
a post-presidency book
by former President Trump
because they do not think
it will be truthful,
and that's just based
on the title.
[ Laughter ]
Former President
Barack Obama said,
in an interview
published yesterday,
"If you watch Fox News,
you perceive a different reality
than if you read
The New York Times."
For example,
if you only watch Fox,
you might not know that
some women have brown hair
[ Laughter ]
According to reports,
Brisbane, Australia,
will be announced as the hos
of the 2032 Olympics.
Even crazier,
Tokyo, Japan,
will host the Olympics
in 2021.
[ Laughter ]
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said,
in a recent interview,
that nothing keeps him
up at night more than,
"what's happening
in our universities
and on our campuses today.
What's that,
the overpriced tuition,
the sexual assault, the hazing
Oh, right, the learning.
According to reports,
a recent data breach
of the burger chain McDonald's
disclosed the square footage
of restaurant play areas.
And this is alarming --
those ball pits are
30-feet deep!
[ Laughter ]
Tesla CEO Elon Musk
announced yesterday
that he was planning to sell
his last remaining house
in San Francisco,
as part of his commitment
to liquidate his possessions
to fund a colony on Mars.
That story again --
a house in San Francisco
costs as much
as a colony on Mars.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
at least 14 people
have already been arrested
this year
for trying to enter Disney World
while carrying a gun.
"Listen, sometimes these peopl
get a little crazy,"
said Mickey.
[ Laughter ]
At least he seems happy
about it.
According to reports, a pop-up
coronavirus vaccine site
in New York's Times Square
gave nearly 900 patients
expired doses
of the Pfizer shot.
Patients became worried
the moment they saw the doctor
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we'll go Mickey/Elmo
back-to-back.
[ Laughter ]
We don't care.
We'll mix the worlds.
[ Laughter ]
The world's tallest
single-rail roller-coaster
opened over the weekend
at Six Flags Great Adventure
in New Jersey,
which is 13 stories high;
while the world's
longest roller-coaster
is still Bennifer.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, the Girl Scout
announced yesterday
they have 15 million boxes
of unsold cookies this year,
due to coronavi--
Excuse me.
[ Laughing ] Due to --
Alright.
Still laughing
about the Bennifer joke.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, the Girl Scout
announced yesterday
they had 15 million boxes
of unsold cookies this year,
due to COVID restrictions,
which they should have known was
a terrible name for a cookie
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
that, right there,
I think we can all agree,
was a monologue.